do you feel like
like
where are the guys that are just willing
to go out there and do comedy do they
still exist there's oh my god there's
because it's not funny a lot of this is
not funny
there's very very
small
group and i think it's just the ones
that are in the clubs like in new york
and the seller and he's still doing his
thing by the way yeah
good good on you i just you you i'm
telling you right now
this comedy is a dying art i'm like yes
the greats are killing it but if you
can't say certain words like yo if it's
a story about you and it's your life and
i can't talk about it because the group
is going to be offended the hell out of
here like i did i did a kevin hart half
an hour special and in the joke this is
just this is my life uh my my neighbor
was a tall gay guy and he saw me with
the with the gun jack i went shooting
and he was the name of germaine he's
like oh my god like is that your gun and
i'm like yeah he goes my two friends are
in the apartment i just went to go get
them weed they never give me money can
you come in with your put a mask on and
i swear to god so i go yeah so for the
joke as i kick in the door and i go
there's two trainees in there they bleep
that out of the out of my my comedy
thing and they put like a
voiceover of gay and i was like there
were two guys that were [ __ ] they
were transvestite oh i couldn't
abbreviate their like what they were
cause that's like a slur now that's a
slur and i'm like no i didn't want to
say there was too true i i just put it
into the joke and i'm like yeah man we
have to bleep it we had to cut it out
and we just put it wasn't even my voice
it was like gays they just put gay guys
like y'all ruined the whole night that's
not funny anymore
it's crazy we talk about shows here that
like married with children or like shows
that you would just never
crazy you can't even friends like we did
a breakdown of like friends and like all
the stuff that happened on that show
that was the 90s that now if it rolled
out
forget it and the producer uh one of the
writers actually came out and said you
know well this wasn't a racially diverse
cast and i have regrets and all that
shut then give us the money back you'll
get the money now go give them
i mean because you it's white people now
i know a living single was the black
version of it like just shot everybody
i'm telling right now there needs to be
a movement of
like i want to say like [ __ ] your
feelings but more of like you bro
who cares right like art is art you know
i'm saying if you paint something
somebody goes i don't i don't like can
you as an artist can you take off the
red
[ __ ] you
five years to paint this i'm sorry red
bothers your eyes i ain't changing [ __ ]
right that's it and i think and these
people like this like us that i don't
give a [ __ ] because y'all this is who i
am yeah if you don't like it don't watch
it change the channel move on it's like
i'm not going to make everybody happy
people are going to hate you people hate
me
and you know what the thing is people
still watch that show
like they will not watch stuff that
comes out now because it's all woke i
mean the new sex in the city was
ridiculous i like the horrible whack i
need this i couldn't get through much of
it but honestly every single component
of it was like how do we incorporate
this woke talking point how do we make
this you know whether it was about
whatever like how do we make that the
show and it was just like spot the woke
talking point it was sad because that
show was a good show back in the day of
course it didn't they didn't carry
through samantha and samantha was the
best character but you know people watch
friends because they're like i want to
remember when [ __ ] was just funny and we
weren't so worried about you know how
everybody was going to feel about it and
that's why now you ask people what shows
they watch
and we're going to get into that in a
second actually what a fantastic segue
it's all really
lovely look are we going through a
nostalgia burnout it's an article in
refinery29 that talks about how even
like shows like stranger things is
popular i don't know if you watched that
show but what's the first season i'm not
going to find i haven't been but it's
all like 80s stuff like you feel like
you're reliving your childhood it's all
like the stuff
yes
yes and this article talks about how
like there's reunions there's reboots
and people are more plugged into that
than they are to any modern productions
that are coming out because they're
boring
they're woke they're being safe they're
being like like that's why like you
nailed it all these reboots and i like
all that like you what was the one that
you talked about uh married with
children yep
like
shows like that amazing amazing al bundy
the white everybody was their own
character yeah it was a daughter the
daughter was like
what people have to understand is you
are watching a comedy show it's not
called seriousness it's a freaking c
it's a comedy show these are characters
and a make-believe world is there to
make us laugh like that's why a family
family guy pushes the envelope they they
don't bow down south park south park
doesn't bow down and i think it's from
the jump from the rip you have to have
the attitude jedi i don't we don't this
company give a [ __ ] don't like us yeah
move on
that's the problem though right that
even if the writers and even if the
musicians decide they don't give a [ __ ]
it's the company around them like a lot
of these like abc is so woke it's
ridiculous you see what they're doing in
disney cartoons now it's gotta be woke
or it doesn't get past the smell test so
it's like that's the challenge the
record label the like all of these
companies agencies you know of course
sag and you know even the you know the
utas and the you know cas they're all so
woke that you're like even if the artist
doesn't want to follow that path they
feel like well i won't work in this
industry if i don't listen and just
apologize or just shy away from the
challenge is i feel that
the number of topics now that you'd have
to shy away from like you're basically
just massed up on like i don't know how
you talk about as a comedian especially
with stand up you've got to be
spontaneous i don't know how you're just
like what the [ __ ] do i say oh my god
i did a show i was in san diego i did
this like covid uh was it just ending or
i don't know i don't know what i did
pack room my boy josh nelson uh ran the
show i think it was like i forgot the
name of it jed pack room i said
something i think i said something as a
character with china virus whatever i
said you should you could hear the
breath out of the four girls in front
just
she was like and then she was talking
[ __ ] to me the whole show i go i know
what you're offended but they were with
me the audience and i just [ __ ] on her i
just went
if you don't like it then why are you
still sitting here she stayed there for
half an hour i go leave yeah you don't
like it you don't have to sit here if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]